another one of these so-called pro-life
anti-abortion Republicans has now been
caught urging his mistress who he
thought had been impregnated by him to
have an abortion other people shouldn't
have the choice of an abortion according
to Tim Murphy but his mistress and he
really should have that choice I'm
talking of US Republican congressman Tim
Murphy he had an affair with Shannon
Edwards forensic psychologist in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Murphy has
already admitted to the affair or to the
relationship I guess is what they're
calling it he didn't actually get her
pregnant but they had a pregnancy scare
where they thought maybe she's pregnant
and in January text messages that leaked
and were obtained by the Pittsburgh
post-gazette indicated that it appeared
that Tim Murphy while publicly against
legal abortion tried to get his mistress
to have an abortion or would have if the
pregnancy had been real his office's
Facebook account had posted an
anti-abortion message and after that he
had the following text exchanged with
Shannon Edwards where she said quote and
you have zero issue posting your
pro-life stance all over the place when
you had no issue asking me to abort our
unborn child just last week when we
thought that was one of the options to
which Tim Murphy replied I get what you
say about my march for life messages
I've never written them staff does them
I read them and winced
I told staff don't write anymore I will
the anti-abortion hard-right Family
Research Council loves this guy life
pack which is against abortion endorsed
Tim Murphy he's part of the house
pro-life caucus he's one of those
pro-life unless I want to force a woman
to have an abortion type of guys here
are some of the votes that Tim Murphy
has cast he voted YES on banning federal
health coverage that includes abortion
he voted YES on making it a crime to
harm a fetus during another crime he
voted yes to ban funding for abortion
under federal Obama care plants he voted
yes to prohibit federal funding for
abortion he voted to prohibit federal
funding to groups like Planned
Parenthood
voted for no family planning assistance
that includes abortion he voted to
include preborn human beings in
Fourteenth Amendment protection he voted
for a permanent ban on the use of
federal funds for abortion or health
coverage that includes abortions and
very recently he co-sponsored and voted
YES on the most recent version of the
20-week abortion ban but he was right
there telling his mistress what about an
abortion that might be a good idea which
are the Family Values the being for
abortion when it suits him or the having
the affair or the telling women when it
might be a good idea for them to get
abortions and as a total aside
he admits in the texts that he's not
writing the anti-abortion nonsense that
his staff posts to Facebook he's
admitting I mean it's so minor in the
grand scheme of things he's admitting
that those messages are just political
posturing the only moral abortion
apparently for Tim Murphy is his own
mistresses abortion but hey this is an
honorable and distinguished member of
the House of Representatives he's not
going to be held to the same standard as
poor people and others it is a
Republican congressman when they need
abortions it is totally different from
when random people need abortions I
guess in his world pathetic
clowns hypocrisy and double standard
doesn't even come close to describing
what these people are advocating and
then doing in their private lives just
absolutely disgusting